the truth is coming out
the truth about all sorts of government
operations over the last few years
certainly the truth about covid which
you and I knew from the beginning you
know I hate to say I told you so and
many of you told me so and each other so
because it was so obvious from the
beginning that if you've got a major bio
lab down the street from where allegedly
this virus came from
and the virus has all these strange
features that we haven't seen before
probably did not come from a bad batch
of bat soup might have had something to
do with the bio lab then when you found
out
that fauci and the National Institutes
of Health were actually funding this
kind of research on back coronaviruses
funding the Wuhan Institute of virology
all of a sudden it seemed pretty obvious
but that's just starting to come out now
another lie that has been dispelled some
truth that's finally coming out now is
that what we were told about January 6th
the worst day in the history of the
Republic what you were told about that
was largely not true the handful of
videos you saw from John you already
sixth were were selected to be the most
violent scary videos you could possibly
see but then when you look at 41
000 hours of security camera footage
from that day
you find out that the image presented in
those videos that the liberal media
exclusively had had put forward did not
accurately reflect what happened the
clearest example of this would be that
the Q Anon Shaman you know the guy with
the horn hat
he he was not this Maniac revolutionary
leader running through the capital as
the police tried to chase him the police
escorted him through
they tried to open locked doors for him
and there were many such cases of that
so how do we know that we know that
because the Republicans one controlled
the house again which meant that Kevin
McCarthy was able to get control of 41
000 hours of security camera footage he
gave that to Tucker Carlson and Tucker's
investigators Tucker released that
footage coincidentally I was on the show
the night that he released it so I'm
sitting there in the green room I
usually don't pay attention to the shows
before I go on them and I'm Spellbound
I'm looking at this footage I said oh my
goodness gracious what we were told is
not really true so how's the White House
reacting to this Kareem Jean-Pierre says
that you need to stop believing your own
Lying Eyes
when you look at the depos it I've been
out there recently it even States from
Fox News leadership that they do not see
Tucker Carlson's show as news or even
truthful that is coming from the fox
leadership that's not coming from me
that is coming from them and I also
would quote I'll paraphrase here what
the chief of Capitol Police said he said
when you watch essentially when you
watch Tucker calls it as it relates to
January 6 it is misleading and it is
misinformation as with the conclusion of
what happened on January 6 the attacks
that happen as you saw from the
president's statement
140 officers were injured nearly 140
officers were injured on that day it was
an attack on our democracy it was an
attack on our Constitution and you
cannot whitewash that Tucker Carlson
cannot whitewash that anyone who doesn't
see with their own eyes what occurred
cannot whitewash that and so the
president is going to stand with the
police officers he's going to stand and
for truth and clearly that is not what
Tucker Carlson believes in
if you've seen him with your own eyes
you you can't whitewash that right the
issue for you guys is that right now
people are seeing this with their own
eyes for the first time they're seeing
lots and lots of security camera footage
and they're seeing that the story that
you presented is not true even down to
the police officers we were told police
officers were killed on January 6th that
was just completely made up and the
newspapers that reported that had to
correct those stories a lot of
newspapers making a lot of Corrections
in recent times but of course the story
runs on the first page the correction
runs on page Z ten thousands of many
fewer people see that but that's not my
issue here
my issue is not that the White House is
criticizing Tucker Carlson of course
that's going to happen it's not that the
White House is trying to spin and trying
to tell people not to pay any attention
to the New Evidence that's come out
my issue is that last line
Tucker Carlson he doesn't believe in the
truth
Tucker Carlson he's not on the side of
the truth
this coming from the libs
who constantly insist that objective
truth does not exist
that's my big problem with it this was
the topic one of the topics of my speech
last night at the University of Buffalo
the question of transgenderism the
question of feminism the question of all
these ideologies
it seems to me would be is it true or is
it false and yet whenever you bring this
up to a liberal
they'll say oh
who cares they'll say who cares they'll
say what is truth they'll say whose
truth is it your truth is it my truth
they'll say there's no objective truth
that's a construction of the evil white
male patriarchy how dare you use the t
word in here
just just much Lamer versions
of the same cynical question going all
the way back to Pontius Pilate
who when Christ says I am the truth
Pontius Pilate says what is truth that's
what the libs say
and now Kareem Jean-Pierre and the White
House has the audacity to say
Tucker Carlson doesn't believe in the
truth half this country doesn't believe
in the truth and it's not our half it's
not the conservative half we're the ones
who are just trying to to keep hold of
any semblance of the truth at all
while the libs say that boys or girls
and girls are boys and Up Is Down and
black is white
we're just saying no come on they'll say
no
in this modern world anything can be
anything
in the world of post-modernism in the
world of dairy da in the world of
Foucault in the world that students are
taught now they are educated to believe
that there is
there is no such thing as outside of the
text it's a famous line from from uh
literary criticism in our post-modern
crazy era there's there's nothing
outside of the text there's nothing
there's no there's no objective reality
it's all just the meaning that we make
of it man it's all just whatever you
think you think you're a woman well
you're a woman you think you're a cat I
guess you're a cat who's to say
who's to say but Tucker Carlson doesn't
believe in the truth because he's
playing videos of what actually happened
for his audience hello pot hello pot
would you like to meet kettle
I mentioned I was at the University of
Buffalo
last night had a great time really
really packed house
unfortunately we were not able to get a
larger venue so this speech was in a
venue that I think was
we were only permitted to seat 300
people we had we were allowed to do a
little bit of Standing Room on the side
but there were a thousand people outside
and half of the thousand people were
there screaming their heads off and
saying that they I should be killed and
shrieking all sorts of bizarre
obscenities and then the other half was
there it is to come in and see the
speech most of the people who made it in
to see the speech were on the
open-minded inquisitive calm normal side
of things there were a handful of
protesters
who were sitting there and then almost
the moment I opened my mouth they
started shrieking trans lives about her
trans lives matter and I said okay I
think I think I got the point
translating them the police had to try
them haul them out of there because they
just wouldn't wouldn't move and they
only knew about six or seven words so
that it was not a particularly
interesting dialogue
but we survived I you can watch the
speech right now on the yaf YouTube
channel the thing that most struck me
about going to the University of Buffalo
where there was this major major protest
pretty much every news organization from
the Buffalo area had come in there were
multiple there was a press conference
the day before about what I might say
that the University president had to
answer for this the Sunni the State
University of New York the whole system
of SUNY Schools Board of Trustees and
Chancellor released a statement about
how terrible I am which
did not speak very well of SUNY because
they apparently didn't understand the
basic meaning of my words but all of
this I'm not I'm not just saying you
know it's a Big Show and you should all
show up to the next show though
obviously you should the reason I
mention all of this is because
there was so much press there was so
much publicity there was so much hubbub
and then when it got to the questioners
when it got to the Q a part at the end
the liberal critics who were in the room
didn't know what I believe
that was what was so striking
there could not have been more publicity
about the things that I say and think
that spurred all of this protest going
back last week to my speech at CPAC all
the way up to the event last night
people were being inundated in the
Buffalo area with information about what
I have allegedly said and believed And
yet when the questioners got up there
they had no idea what I thought
a guy gets up there he says Michael
you have said that
uh sex and gender is is purely a
physical factor of biological sex
now I'm just using that one example
because I've talked about it on the show
quite a lot how many times have I said I
don't think that human nature is only
about biology I think that man is body
and spirit I think the gender expression
is a legitimate way of talking about a
real phenomenon which is the the
metaphysical answer to our physical
nature and how often do I I talk about
that all the time I frequently say I'm a
little different than other conservative
commentators on this issue because I
think that the when people talk about
gender expression they're really just
trying to talk about the soul which is
obviously an important part of human
nature so I talk about this all the time
I'm not saying that these protesters
need to listen to every episode of my
show or even any episode of my show but
my question is if you've never listened
to a thing that I've actually said why
would you show up screaming protesting
saying that people have to kill me
why
Rush Limbaugh used to have this
people used to believe they earnestly
believed that they knew what Rush
Limbaugh had believed and had said
none of these people had ever listened
to one single episode of The Rush
Limbaugh Show so how did they think that
they knew what he thought because they
heard three words on MSNBC because they
saw some press release for Media Matters
half the time the the news clip or the
press release didn't even accurately
reflect Russia's words but they formed
this image in their mind and it just
wasn't true and and coincidentally this
was the topic
of the speech last night
on feminism and how feminism gave us
transgenderism since everybody's talking
about transgenderism now
the the transgender
activists
who say that we're killing everybody and
we're evil and we're terrible we need to
be shut down and shut up and locked up
they're convinced that we're wrong
we who hold to The View
that everybody held of human nature from
prehistory until approximately
five minutes ago we are definitely
totally hatefully wrong
and they the people who hold a view that
was invented
within the last eight years as a matter
of public life they are totally 100
correct and they know that they're
correct because some man feels that he
is a woman or some woman feels that she
is a man but the question you've got to
ask is
it possible
you're wrong
this was my question to I talked to some
protesters after well we'll hopefully be
able to get some of that video up I
talked to protesters after the speech
and they kept telling me things that I
believe that I don't actually believe
that I haven't said that I've regularly
contradicted
and I think if you can be so wrong about
that if you're going to be so wrong
about this relatively minor political
event that you've spent the last week
wasting all of your time plotting trying
to get shut down screaming making
posters showing up threatening people if
you could be wrong about that is it
possible
that you were also wrong when you a man
say that you are a woman is that
possible that's my only question for
them it is fake headline Friday I've got
my fake headlines I've got a lot more
not just voicemail bag
regular written mailbag we got
everything man I still have a little bit
of coffee we're good see over there at
the member block if you were not a
member yet
delaware.com use code nulls
and get two months free at checkout see
you over there
[Music]